hello everyone on behalf of Agri links
be the future and the USAID bureau for
food security I would like to welcome
you to our webinar today on
strengthening private sector Extension
and advisory services in an
international development context my
name is Julie McCarty and I am your Agri
links webinar host with the USAID bureau
for food security I'll be your webinar
facilitator today so you'll hear my
voice periodically especially during our
question-and-answer session but before
we dive into the content I would like to
go over a few items to orient you to the
webinar first please do use the chat box
to introduce yourself to ask questions
at any point and to share any resources
you may have that are relevant to the
topic today and thank you to everyone
who's introduced yourselves already we
always love to see that we have a global
audience for these webinars we'll be
collecting your questions throughout the
webinar and will pause after each
speaker for a couple of questions and
the speakers will also answer some of
the questions in the chat box along the
way and then we'll probably wind up
saving the bulk of the questions until
after the three presentations today
lastly we are recording this webinar and
we will e-mail you the recording the
transcript and any additional
recommended resources once they are
already perhaps in about a week and half
time or so and they'll also be posted on
the Agri links org website okay onwards
to our presentations and our discussions
on extension in today's webinar the Feed
the Future developing a local extension
capacity project also known as Dilek
will present results of a portfolio
review exploring recent experience and
potential for expanding private sector
extension and advisory services for the
AG sector in addition to the initial
presentation on this select study our
webinar today will also cover two case
studies of private sector extension
which I'm really excited about one in
Senegal and one in Uganda the webinar
speakers will give recommendations for
expanding private sector
extension services through future US aid
projects and other investments okay I
think we're pretty much ready to dive in
so I'm going to introduce our first
speaker who will then introduce our
subsequent speakers and then we can get
started
Christine Davis is a senior research
fellow with the International Food
Policy Research Institute or if pre
where she has been since 2004 and her
work involves research and capacity
strengthening on Agricultural Extension
education and agricultural innovation
systems and she is currently the project
co-director for the Felix project funded
by US aid which she will be talking
about now during a webinar so I'll pass
the microphone over to Kristin thanks
very much Julie good day to everyone
yeah from my side I'll be presenting the
study that Julie has mentioned on
private sector extension and then we'll
be hearing from two case studies from
Uganda and Senegal and as Julie
mentioned there'll be questions in
between you can use the chat box for
questions too so after I present the
study which you can download in the
links box on the Left there's an
overview and the full study after my
presentation we'll hear from Robert and
Yong from Kim onyx international Roberts
and agricultural value trained
improvement and marking a marketing
expert he's got 23 years of experience
applying the facilitative approach to
market systems and value chain
development so you'll be hearing about
that when he presents the village agent
model from Uganda he's currently the
agriculture and food security adviser
for eastern and southern Africa region 4
come onyx and Robert has worked in
extension programs in 19 countries in
sub-saharan Africa working to strengthen
public private extension capacity and
also with digital technologies and then
we'll hear also from John Michelle
Michelle visage from RTI he's based in
the car in Senegal and
is a senior market systems advisor at
RTI International and jean-michel has
worked twenty years in the West African
region linking private sector banks
grassroots rural organizations to build
sustainable market systems that benefit
small farmers and jean-michel has been a
chief of party and technical advisor to
the Feed the Future
that's Harlan by projects so he'll be
presenting that but let me give a little
bit of introduction to delectable ocol
extension capacity this is a Feed the
Future project implemented by digital
green together with if free care
international the Global Forum for rural
advisory services and we do work closely
with the CGIAR
research program on policies
institutions and markets
Dilek strengthens extension in Feed the
Future and aligned countries through
three interlay interrelated sets of
activities these are Diagnostics studies
such as we're presenting today on the
private sector extension we've also done
10 or 11 studies on assessments of
extension in Feed the Future countries
we also get involved in pilot
engagements on the ground in different
countries implementing best practices
that we found through the Diagnostics
and then we bring all the learning from
the Diagnostics and engagements to the
extension community in countries and
globally through communities of practice
such as we're doing today so let me dive
right in I think Julie mentioned that we
want to summarize lessons learned and
also options to expand private sector
extension and advisory services we call
it EAS at times through future US aid
projects but also other investments and
the study inputs are including a global
literature review I'll touch on that
briefly and also a rapid desk review of
US aid investments in 28 Feed the Future
and aligned countries as I'm sure you're
aware extension is recognized as
essential for program
who are trying to transform AG systems
governments and other investors who want
to address global social and economic
development objectives such as reducing
food insecurity poverty etc and both
public and private organizations are
active in extension and advisory
services in most countries just to
define for you who are we talking about
with private sector actors and you'll
hear excellent examples from Robert and
Jean Michel we're talking about
basically all the non-governmental
actors so we're talking about both
nonprofit and for-profit entities these
includes civil society and NGOs who are
trying to advance their organisational
mandate it includes input suppliers and
other for-profit entities they want to
sell products they want to please their
customers it includes people like
product buyers who are trying to get
adequate supplies of good quality
commodities we also have consultants and
consulting firms who are selling their
services the media are also often
for-profit marketing information
services and then we have producer
organizations who want to service or
represent their groups interests so
we'll be hearing about them in more
detail from my presentation and the case
studies the private sector has always
complimented public sector extension and
advisory services and you might notice
in the report and then the presentation
that we talk a lot about the public
sector still and that comes because of
the portfolio review that we did we saw
a strong role still of the public sector
they important to complement the private
sector and essential really to meet
objectives of different development
partners and so that's why you hear
about the public sector in this private
sector webinar but I'd like to jump also
into the literature review why the
private sector why private sector
extension and advisory services well
there's a lot of potential for private
sector in terms of providing
sustainability of extension services of
meeting needs of farmers
I'll mention a few of these here they do
increase profits to both the service
provider and to the clientele of the
farmer so their shared value there it's
also used to strengthen long term
business relationships private sector is
good for promoting innovation and
service delivery including the use of
ICTs and the private sector helps to
ensure adequate quantities and quality
of market products and they do
participate as as financers as service
providers as users of extension and
advisory services and we saw that most
US aid extension and advisory service
projects implement by using private
contractors or grantees in addition to
the potential of private sector there's
of course limitations as well and of
course one of these is that they need
cost recovery they're trying to get
their cost back and even make some money
in providing these services and as a
result the coverage isn't always perfect
it's sometimes limited to people who can
afford to pay for services to people
with the higher value crops and other
products sometimes there's a perceived
or an actual conflict of interest for
people like maybe some input providers
who people think are just trying to flog
their product without necessarily you
know caring about the bigger picture of
what the producers need there's also the
case that many extension providers from
the private sector actually lack
experience they lack capacity and
interest in extension and advisory
service provision there's also the issue
of the nature of innovations you know
there's the public versus the private
goods and so certain innovations are
better for the private sector because
commercialization is possible and then
there's other goods such as public goods
natural resource management and so forth
that is less interesting for the private
sector so that's quickly a review of the
literature we want to make time for the
case studies but now I want to walk into
the portfolio review we looked at 28
feed the future and aligned countries
they're listed here and we've been in
touch with many
of you we looked at a hundred and thirty
three projects from the year 2010 to
2019 and these projects that we looked
at these programs were actually quite
complex they had on average three point
six different components or objectives
and some had more than ten so it's quite
a lot that they were taking on only five
of the projects were solely extension
and advisory services and these two of
these were actually implemented by USDA
the United States Department of
Agriculture and about five to ten
percent of the funding of these projects
were for the extension and advisory
services component so that's an overview
of what we looked at for the portfolio
review what we found we looked at first
of all some design considerations when
we looked at these 28 countries and 133
projects design of programs is important
because it establishes the base for
investment success or failure it
determines the nature and extent of the
impact and what we found is there appear
to be some significant design issues for
extension and advisory services and for
effective private sector participation
in the systems the first of these is
that there appeared to be a weak
analytical base for design a lot of the
planning seem to have been maybe ad hoc
done by contractors and grantees during
planning or as they started
implementation and it didn't seem like
the strategy and approach was
necessarily linked to some evidence base
relatedly we didn't find much of an
evidence base for the content that was
being promoted so we weren't sure why
these innovations were being promoted
and how they were linked back to the
needs from the clientele thirdly as I
mentioned the projects are quite complex
you know there's a lot of activities in
many of these projects there's extension
services financial services input supply
producer organizations irrigation
mechanization market development all of
these are needed to enable change at the
farm
but of course with so much complexity so
much going on it's hard to give due
attention to the extension component
specifically and then we found very
ambitious targets many of these were
actually met or even exceeded but one
wonder is when you're trying to reach
such large targets in clientele does it
compromise the quality and the intensity
of the services so those are some design
considerations we also looked at some of
the implementation considerations too
and as I mentioned we found this
surprisingly strong reliance on public
extension and advisory services this was
true in almost all the projects even
those with weak extension services and
of course it's necessary to gain access
to communities validate legitimacy and
of course to provide content backup and
so forth but that was found across the
board in terms of methodologies very
traditional we found farmer training
demonstration field days and a
sprinkling of others like mass media
Affairs and so forth which is fine
traditional methodologies are great
where they work and as you see in point
three radio was very common and very
effective but we found limited
applications of other information and
communication technologies or ICTs and
effective communication is really at the
heart of extension and advisory services
so we might want to consider other
applications of ICTs fourthly subsidies
for inputs were very common they're
often used to encourage adoption which
is great but they are well known to
distort market decisions and to be
unsustainable
of course most EAS programs are
essentially subsidies themselves so then
the issue becomes what do we subsidize
how much and for how long
and then lastly decentralization was a
common issue 15 countries had
decentralized their public systems while
carrying potential benefits they can be
really chaotic disruptive they give new
responsibilities it requires you know
different financial arrangements
different budgeting and so forth
so it's it's quite a long process and
takes a lot of thinking we then looked
at the different project roles that we
found across the board and we found that
producer organizations were ubiquitous
they were used in all of the projects in
all the countries most projects or
evaluation reports that we looked at
identified them as needed strengthening
but very little was actually provided
and now you'll hear more from John
Michell about the use of producer
organizations in the project he's
presenting contact lead farmers farmer
volunteers there's many different names
these were also ubiquitous and they're
important because they link the
providers and the communities they
expand the reach but of course you know
there's there's issues with them which
we can discuss if we have time at the
end as well and then you'll be hearing
more from Robert about the input dealers
but they were very common as well across
the board there's a strong common
interest for promoting the use of inputs
from both you know the projects and the
input providers themselves but we did
find that the capacity the range of
services of input providers was often
limited I want to move now to just
talking about how can we invest what do
we want to promote so that we can expand
and strengthen private sector extension
and advisory services what interventions
can we bring in and I realize this is a
very long list but I'm gonna talk about
each of these points one by one excuse
me so firstly I think this is a big
systems area we need to develop national
extension policies and strategies or if
they are already developed they need to
be strengthened and implemented so the
coherent public sector policies on
extension are key they provide an
enabling environment they either enable
or disable private sector to come in and
so they're very important and one
intervention here for funders whether
there may be programs or projects or fun
of any type including government you can
support formulation of national
extension and advisory service policies
a second intervention is to strengthen
the public sector this as I said before
is a bit counterintuitive but the public
sector really serves as a backbone of
the full extension and advisory service
system so it's important to have a
strong public sector so that we can have
a strong private sector as well thirdly
we need to improve support services for
extension these include things like
training research subject matter
specialists backstopping communications
monitoring and evaluation and so forth
this is important for the private sector
fifthly we want to strengthen producer
organizations they are private sector
entities they're key players for
effective and sustainable extension
systems and I think more intentional
effort is needed to bring more
innovative approaches and to develop
further these organizations and I think
we'll hear more about that from Jean
Michel the sixth point is to strengthen
the input suppliers they were also an
important element for private sector
extension and here we want to focus on
improving professionalism management
quality consciousness and things like
that there's other private sector
providers also that needs strengthening
number seven we need we need to
strengthen potential private sector
providers who might be weak it might be
more efficient it might be more
preferable to strengthen their capacity
give them business plans and business
models before expecting them to engage
effectively in provision of EIS
themselves number eight we want to
strengthen quality certification system
so when we're talking about the private
sector we want to pay attention to the
quality the objectivity the
qualifications of these different
providers and their accountability and a
possibility here might be to fund
technical assistance training or
development costs for a system
to establish standards to register
certified extension providers I think
Roberts gonna touch on that in his
presentation from Uganda and then number
9 there's a need to strengthen and to
establish stakeholder consultation
programs things like innovation
platforms where you bring together the
public sector the private sector
researchers agribusiness farmers to
address specific problems or
opportunities and then there's the issue
of subsidies so you know you might want
to subsidize so that you're promoting
adoption or uptake of innovations early
in a project so you might want to think
about strategically subsidizing and give
things maybe for free or subsidized
initially or or to get things going but
be aware and have a sort of an exit
strategy for how you're gonna phase that
out in the end and then finally the last
investment intervention I think is to
actually directly fund extension
delivery and this is especially the case
where it might be appropriate for
post-crisis countries fragile states
where you're serving disadvantaged
populations or in natural resource
conservation programs so these kinds of
programs have an advantage that there's
a direct link between the funding and
the clientele and their impacts the
disadvantage on the other hand is that
they're generally time can time limited
not sustainable and they're limited in
terms of scale as well one more slide
and then I'll talk about how delet can
come in and help some of the missions
and so forth on this but we sort of
these four recommendations
according to four different scenarios
from a very weak public and weak private
extension system to a very strong and
strong public and strong private system
and if you look in the report on the on
the left that you can download you'll
find preliminary recommendations for
each of the 28 countries the 28
portfolios that
of course these recommendations are
highly tentative because this was a
rapid review for detailed analysis is
needed but we can offer that I'll tell
you in a minute how so starting in the
top box if you have a weak public and a
weak private system like in post crisis
countries those with limited economic
development you might want to have
direct delivery so you want to address
these immediate needs and you want to
focus probably on capacity development
as a high priority especially that of
producer organizations moving down to
the second row if you do have a weak
public but a strong private system this
is probably rare if it exists at all but
you can think about pockets of strong
private sector extension maybe in
countries that have plantation crops or
something like that here you want to
establish the necessary foundation you
want to provide capacity for the public
sector as a priority and in the third
scenario where you have a strong public
but a weak private sector extensions
here's where you want to target support
to strengthen the private sector and
have support services strengthened
technical specialist support and
communications as well and then lastly
if you're in a fortuitous situation that
has a strong public and a strong private
sector you have the basis for a strong
and effective national system and
activities here from donors and other
funders should strengthen capacities but
also focus on coordination and may be
gaps in serving underserved clientele as
well so the takeaway here that we really
want to give you from the report is that
this is a call to investment in national
extension and advisory service system
development so looking at the whole
picture all the different providers from
a pluralistic environment I think the
system development is key for
sustainability efficiency effectiveness
of the private sector and it's been
neglected in the past with inadequate
attention to local capacity development
and to analytical work in extension
and advisory services there's a lot more
recommendations in the overview that you
can download and in the file the full
file as well that I hope you'll take a
look at and give us comments on I just
want to close here before I turn it back
to Julie with mentioning that D Lake the
developing local extension capacity
project can assist us aid missions with
analyses further analysis like a deep
dive into why the private sector is not
working or how it can be strengthened we
can help with project design review
scopes of works or help with workshops
for project design and implementation
suggest consultants and even do
evaluation of extension and advisory
service activities so with that I'm
gonna pause let Julie see if there's
some key questions we want to answer
before turning over to Robert to present
the case study on Uganda great thank you
so much Kristin for that excellent
presentation we've had a few questions
come in at all to you before we move on
let's see do t-pain former USAID member
asked do you have any sense of the
number of farmers reached by various
approaches in this study radio is of
course common and effective do you have
any numbers on other digital tools or
services Thanks hi hi Judy I knew we'd
hear from you on the digital side we
don't have specific we'd we didn't
aggregate as to the number reached by
different tools and approaches in all
from the the review the portfolio review
it was reported that 89 million farmers
were reached so it was a huge reach but
I think it was through all the different
methods and of course radio Reach is
probably by far the most of them but we
don't have specific information at the
at this report level of how many were
reached by the different digital tools
great thank you and a question from
Gordon OTN Oh ones are how do you assess
the strength weakness of an extension
and advisory service public or private
is there a specific tool that you use
for assessing then thanks Gordon
we don't have a specific tool I think
there's people working on these types of
issues we can sort of use the elements
that I've outlined here in in the
presentation and the report and if you
go to download the huge report the big
full report we have sort of a decision
tree at the end which can help you see
which direction you should go in in
order to intervene but I can I can talk
to you maybe I can use the chat box
after and talk about some other
initiatives that are going on to assess
extension in general not just private
sector great thank you I think we'll
throw in one or two more short questions
and then if you also wouldn't mind
helping to answer some in the chat box
once Robert gets underway
let's see Liz so go to asked do you have
any scenario time scales for how long it
would take to implement some of these
best fit recommendations assuming some
regionality or shared environment etc
scenario timelines everything takes
longer than you expect
for instance I I'm based in South Africa
and I have been assisting or I had
assisted with the development of a
national extension policy and it took
years I know you you know Uganda has
been going through something similar and
Malawi is in the in the process of sort
of revising their national policy it
takes a long time and you have to be
ready you know for sort of the long haul
in some of these systems development
areas in
terms of regionality yeah I'm assuming
you're talking about learning across the
region but yeah I think we always need
to plan for longer longer than we expect
[Music]
you have any any plans perhaps for a
question from Erna Abidine are there any
plans for how to link this USAID funded
program to any nonprofit NGOs outside of
US aid or or to other entities outside
of US aid or outside of it free yeah
thanks yeah so so the developing local
extension capacity is a is a Feed the
Future project that's focused on Feed
the Future countries those are listed
I'll share the link or somebody can
share the link in the chat box in a
moment what the Feed the Future
countries are but we do work with other
partners depending on what the needs are
in that country so for instance in
Nigeria we worked with a private sector
company that wasn't you know part of
Feed the Future necessarily and in other
countries we've been working with with
NGOs in Bangladesh for instance so it's
not you know we can link up with other
with other nonprofit entities depending
on you know the joint interests the the
shared objectives in the country where
we're working
great Thank You Christian in the
interest of time I think we can move
along but we will continue to address
questions in the chat box and at the end
of the presentation so next we'll move
along to Robert and yang for his portion
of the presentation Thank You Julia
Thank You Julie and thanks a lot
Christian for that wonderful
presentation I am also very super
excited to talk about extension after
spending 90 years trying to find ways to
make it cheaper and affordable to most
care FAMAS the late norman borlaug used
to tell us I actually work for Sasakawa
epic Association before I joined
harmonics if you say take technology
closer to the farmers in terms of
innovations and information and instead
employers find means of doing that so
that can be sustainable over the years
we try so many models with my man
league's approach the these quality
community-based by setting by another
day as soon as we stop funding it it all
stops so we start taking how do we do it
better and that's what I want to share
with you today we all know in extension
the biggest cost is not wages or salary
the biggest cost is logistics and
training actually logistic takes 58% of
all extension delivery both public and
private sector extension systems now
let's talk about the public a second
delivery system in Uganda I'm sure it's
not different from any other countries
we we do have a ratio of extension
worker to Pharma at one one one
essential worker to want other iterate
farmers may be unconscious like utopia I
can't find one to 500 meaning we are not
reaching out to farmers in a proper way
and if we take a look at the advert the
private sector you know the private
sector has about four models they
promote the family led model which is
mostly to improve formal situation and
offer them better opportunities which I
did for 14 years and to empower farmer
and we the donors keep on finding aids
as soon as we pull out it it goes back
to the same way we met it the global
sourcing module is a welder modules
across in big commodities mostly to
secure life supplies and have like
impact on on farmers but it also have
their drawbacks mostly you find there's
a high rates of side selling by the same
producers and it sometimes offer the
systems of commercial service to these
farmers then you have the local traders
models they are very efficient in
sourcing they reach the farmer home they
these guys you find on bicycle go to
Amazon to pick up one bag of maize but
did there's always issue of mistrust
among each of them and and definitely
always causing problems between farmers
and traders then we'll have the
specialized models like Christy
mentioned about consultants
yeah just are the ones trying to improve
and innovate I gotta buy the chains use
of ICT user means over here for mass but
make it for profits but is also his own
drawbacks is have high initial cost of
investment so we keep on thinking how do
we do it in an effective and affordable
way I was the chief of party of a
project called the commodity production
market activity Uganda that ended in
March 2018 and then we decided to
combine all of these models together
they form a late models the specialized
models the local traders and the global
sourcing and we find a commonality among
all this we try to find out we the last
person the rich other farmer in all
these models they all have alcohol and
agents and why do we decide to work with
such people we believe the biggest
problem in supply chain is size selling
and reaching out from us on terms of
quality and quantity so but but working
with the same guys that does in most
Harbach which are the traders may be we
able to improve the system by a coaching
and mentoring them so on that our
program we can what we call the village
agent model
and this height works is a market-driven
approach we first engaged a market pool
the market pool means the end buyer the
person that signals what he wants in
terms of quantity and quality is at an
exporter or or an buyer or likes
processing companies then he and the
five traders traders can be cooperatives
or modernizations hoppers organizations
or miss Morley traders individual
traders and these same contracts and say
okay this is what we want to do this is
the amount of maize or coffee or beans I
like to buy so can you please make up
how you gonna do the production contract
if you have signed a contract with the
exporter and each other and advice
relate agent who a lawyer to him
remember the village agent is the one
that lives in the village with it with
your farmer easy one to push to call the
shack the coyote the long shot that give
loans to farmers and high rates but he
knows every farmer in the village
because he stays in there and he is a
point of entry because he moves from
home to home to pick a bag of maize or
two bags of maize so if you train those
ones to provide extension in terms of
production and marketing services maybe
we're able to be able to improve the
life of the farmer because remember I
said the biggest cost in extension is
logistics
this agent go from home to home to pick
back up maze without being paid but I
get it Commission for do units so they
are being motivated by based on the
volume they collect and which they get
paid by their traders in terms of
Commission so what we do as CPM we call
it the comma to push on magnet IVA T we
mentor and coach them in different
services on the up pre-production
production and post office emergency
services and part of them we would train
them to be crop insurance agents because
it was demand for crop insurance we
train them to be Impuls of supply
services because they can actually
forecast demand between the needs Alfama
and seed companies they provide planted
services they were training winning
services we are traded in fortune
services but I
agent takes only four to five of these
services to get yourself a Popeye the
wall yeah let me tell you what makes it
interesting for them to do it the agent
makes an average of four thousand
dollars in profits from doing this
twenty services and that's a motivation
that drives them to reach out to the
farmers knowing fully well the more
farmers will improve their production
the more Commission I get from my trader
and how did it deliver services to
farmers because they are used to Vince
from us at the home so individual
farmers it was easy for them to
understand to do but we incorporate
things like ammunition videos on their
tablets I think Christian has been
talked about edited means of linking
from us we develop animation videos to
help them pass the message in a very
eloquent way to promise because you know
most of us who are not well trained
extension workers so we have to make
sure the messages is clear and able to
divide they also promote do a second
delivery by doing one called demand
created demonstrations these are the
typical demonstrations they have signed
contract with input companies but this
is to create demand so they can make
money from it and they often provide
direct service to farmers by going there
to spray take care of the coffee and
wait for them amazing other methods we
use was user I see I see because
definitely they are very versatile in in
communicating in their local languages
so we translate that with the mission of
Agriculture all the essential materials
into local languages for them to achieve
delivered from us and it's often to use
the nice group training I'm home visit
among all these associate degree methods
they use the individual visits and all
visits was the most common among which
was effective to reach out the numbers
of Hamas
how did they make money and sustain a
model and a bag of on one bad or
fatality cell and agent make within five
to six dollar profits so meaning if I
have to read from a problem for me I
said 20 bucks or fertilizers that means
I can be able to get 100 dollars
and how I will surely get his money
remember every seed company or
fertilizer company needs to reach out to
the plumber the cost of the reaching out
to the farmer is almost around 35% so
this money is now half of it is not
given to the agent because Dave we find
out where the farm as a and they would
deliver it but Reza to the farmer at his
doorstep and also provide were called
and better services and this was worked
well and in terms of soy testing they
provide such tests in the mill at five
dollars what would this site testing
companies they had like my fear is when
they spray the megabyte 0.5 dollars in
every liter they make money along the
chain every service they provide overall
I was like to measure impact and say
okay as it's making any changes in the
period of five years from 2013 to 2018
we found a lot of changes are out goes
truth just quick to the slide that was
about their districts tension our target
was to reach our two numbers of Hamas
who have applied new technologies our
baseline was 52,000 but but because the
extension ID built agent model work
effectively we're able to reach by for a
ninety six thousand the a great numbers
of family agent was around to hundreds
of per agent meaning closer and easy
tool to manage the investment by the
private sector because they found that
they could get more supplies and more a
better quality they invested in things
like prison facilities they invested in
things like a provide loans to trade us
to buy more and you know the see the
inputs delivery oh by a pillar of five
years this agent was able to sell 5
million dollars worth of inputs that
reach out to farmer
and we did a survey trying to find out
how many this farmers actually an
apposite benefits of using inputs we
found our seventy percent of these
people appreciate them village agent
driven service to them in a better way
now in every model there's things that
can make it's filled and I've talked
about this more during our inception
period we found out most people tend to
see the traders at the battery put to
work weights and most donors and angels
don't want to associate with them but if
you look at the value chain it trader
has been there all these days and
meaning we can work with the traders to
reach out to farmers because yet it
closes in that model to a farmer if it
do not refuse to work with the middle
actors the VA would not work because
every farmer sees the donors and NGOs as
the next ATM machine meaning they look
for free services they are looking for
dependence on a subsidized ation if
there's no access to finance it will not
work and if there's no lack of
instrument to import production in
practice and behaviors among Aptos the
model would not walk so all this was
considered we are trying to do this what
have you learned there must be a link
here buyer you can owe increase
production without selling it out will
it adjust it to be trained about it's a
visa offer the job decrypt must be
passive as formal well must be willing
to pay for service in cash or in kind at
the same time of delivery ICT is key to
reduce costs of transaction and there
must be a behavior change strategy for
all Aptos
work together over the years the
government of Uganda adopted the model
and then it was under idea called
international approach to extension
policy where you have all essential
services both public and private sector
come to work together and the government
fraternity right now they are providing
support to certify these agents they
provide allies for their staff to reach
out to this agent and also provide the
essential material for this agent to
walk on the private sector this support
is the assertion of workers which
depends to enumerate them to organize
training I also supported us vh2
decimated knowledge and conduct
demonstrations and it is a perfect way
where you find - straighten both public
and private sector
we know the purpose of Mendoza have
sufficient money of funds to reach out
to farmers but the private sector is
with feisty-pants
to support a double session water had to
trim agents who in turn chain the
farmers and it's easy to manage so what
is unique about the agent village agent
model is market driven service
appropriate to farmer because the agents
leaves the same trick with the farm
inputs genuine inputs because the agent
is screwed up to the farm and there's no
way he don't sell fake fake inputs
compared to stockists wolves in town
there's real-time guidance they form a
character to refer to the to the agent
who would live next door to him is
self-sustaining because the agent mixed
money with it was working and it creates
employment I like to talk about the top
takeaways here
remember all key for actors should be
involved exporter traders agent and fama
technology is key as innovations to
deliver better services a man should be
willing to pay for service in Pinal -
the most beautiful incentives around
service delivery racial building is fee
based on trust and loyalty you need to
enhanced against knowledge in relevant
fields and answer to finance by all the
form a Aptos is team thank you very much
wonderful thank you so much Robert will
pause here for a few questions for you
as we've had some great questions for
you come in the first one that I'll ask
you is from mark blackish who asks what
do you think of the strategy for the
Ministry of Ag in Uganda to lead on the
village agent model do you think this
should be a joint initiative with the
Ministry of Trade industry and
cooperative thank you Mark yes I believe
it should be joint effort between the
Ministry of choice you take the lead of
trying to promote the village against
model in this aspect because this false
trade falls under the mission of trade
and definitely walk into the district
commercial business but the myths about
culture can provide ETA to improve the
production petabytes remember this model
is both production and marketing the
brush size is where the missile culture
tried to make sure to improve the yields
by training the VHD provided right
services the McArdle part is where the
myth of trade takes object trading
compaero bit but overall it was with
joint initiative right now
we definitely had a joint initiative
between the Minister of Trade and
industries and the Michelin culture and
a miss of local governments these are
three key partners what take initiative
in this from Jonathan Hobson how do you
ensure that the village agent model
promotes improved cultural practices I
believe thanks Jonathan the assistant of
a bridge agent is based on a two-way
walking with the with a farmer because
input is part of it but remember inputs
alone cannot really buddy the yield you
want so he was traded from us to adopt
better practices and in doing so he's
ensure that better yields is there so
the training they get from things like
donors like a like a car program and
also a miserable culture is true for
them to train to finance better to use
the inputs input is not already and
means we have a lot to do with in it
most of this agent are also involved in
output marketing while they do both ways
input and output marketing so they have
to make sure that he used is sourced and
for them for the farmers to get more
yield so they can buy more from the
farmers so definitely beyond inputs they
have to train from us on how to improve
but therefore our practices and the
return let me be honest with you they do
it because of the motivation of getting
more more yields from the farmers by
training these people
thanks so much over another couple of
questions I'll combine a couple from
Gordon ones re and from Henry Perry what
are some of the risks associated with
the village agents for example monopoly
in the village biased towards some
farming families trust or mistrust and
how did the project handle these risk
and kind of in a similar vein what is
one way to eliminate people's mistrust
of agents in this model thank you very
much
as I said one of the kitchens need to do
is you have to have a behavior change
strategy in place but the mistress has
been a long way you cannot change
overnight
so during the program we try to create
internship between traders and farmers
bring them together to understand what
are the key problems affecting the
relationships we spend over two years
doing that after five years and when the
pharmacy that he needs the agents more
and the agency DePalma then he had
people call a lawyer and Trust and we
develop some materials that have system
to able to understand the biggest
problem in mistrust between an agent and
a farmer is Chile as it's cheating
most from us will say triggers cheats
off by tampering with his skills and
moisture doesn't say from us cheetahs by
adding stones in a bag so we decided to
tap out the skills but when you build a
very good bigger chain strategy teaching
everybody the reason why you are trying
to cheat each other is because your
production is not efficient and if we
here here is going to train you how to
produce better in so are we getting
eight bags of maize and an acre you can
definitely get twenty bucks an acre so
why do you decide to cheat by adding
those two each and this in turn returns
back to the agent
it doesn't to tamp out the with the
woody scale anymore now how do you
reduce monopoly now I'm tell you from us
knows what to do there's no issue
monopoly a farmer live in a village with
different shoes would walk with the
there are no good agents and in no bad
agents they know where as we assisted
them in kind of their need so is the
choices made up to the
mama and the family decide who to work
with in a village you may find about
four agents working for different
traders or you may find one age for
traders at one village agent working for
one trader but the pharma is wise enough
to decide we want to walk with Miss on a
JPL's build a long time ago great thank
you so much Robert let me toss out one
or two more questions to you before we
move on who sustains the cost of the
ICTs and data storage in your model the
pharmacist changes with the trailer the
data collected currently right now from
as a pain about $2 $2 to get a land to
get the Lance profile the land size the
data collect from them it was about $2
and I believe $2 is like a five kilos of
maize all right what now often traders
pay for this on behalf of the farmer and
adopted from the amazement at delivering
it so and that data is kept by a company
called Orion and other ones in settle
and this is high source in itself but in
Uganda the actual cost for pulling that
data is only two dollars which is
sometimes five kilos of maize or two
pillars of beans and it should happen
wide and PMPA with the pharma and adopt
is when if I'm eyes delivering it goes
to him great thank you Robert in the
interest of time I think we'll move on
to our next case study and next
presenters but Robert please do take a
look at the additional questions that
have come in for you in case you can
answer some of the chatbox and of course
we can also answer some more at the end
of the presentation so I'd like to pass
the microphone over to Jean Michelle
buzzard who has another case study for
us so Michelle okay hello Julie thank
you
can you hear me yes you sound clear okay
great well hello everyone from Senegal
okay
so this is about the Senegal net found
by project which actually was closed out
last June
Senegal natal bag was a feed the future
value chain activity that targeted the
Nogales three main cereals rice maize
and millet it came after a predecessor
project called project cotton economy
that had successfully tested a bottom-up
approach that relied on local farmer
organizations for the delivery of
extension and value change services so
Nathon buys goal was to scale the
adoption of technologies and practices
that were identified as promising and
that network model was expected to be
scaled up now not owned by as the
project had a very ambitious coverage
target the idea was to cover forty
percent on average of the household the
rural household with its zone of
influence which is quite large it also
had ambitious technical goals for
example achieving widespread Geographic
and population coverage making sure that
adoption of technologies was lasting
across the board and that all of this
results in systemic transformation in
the delivery of production post harvest
and financial services so we were really
looking at something transformational
however apart from direct technical
assistance and facilitation the project
was only able to rely on the
subcontracting fund with a focus on
local service contracts and we did not
have any grant facility so wait wait
here we go
sorry I went through that first
insurance slide but the most important
one is the next one so strategically to
be able to achieve that scaling and and
also having in-depth technology adoption
we the project established its total
footprint during the first year I mean
right from the start this gave it for
seasonal cycle over which targeted
communities could progressively adopt
technologies and practices while
expanding their membership through what
you know is today called scaling in
process the project then selected
therefore selected a base of 120 pre
established producer networks made up
mainly of cooperatives but also some
very local NGOs and a handful of SME
aggregators that relied exclusively on
small holder sourcing in a structured
way now these networks were contracted
on a year-to-year basis to be the ones
that deliver productivity training and
develop new value change services in an
independent way now under these
contracts that works typically needed to
set up a homegrown extension team
composed of a database manager field
agent and leaf farmers who acted as
village contact points the database
managers and the database managers and
the field agent roles required advanced
literacy and the ability to adopt IT
technologies and so were generally
recruited locally by the networks
amongst the zones young educated youth
there are some even in the most remote
area but the minimum schooling level was
set at tenth grade level and that was
sufficient to ensure competent database
managers so as we said you know the
project picked us on the technological
portfolio that was inherited from this
year but that eventually evolved the
idea here is was to have the network's
progressively become
trusted market agents at their community
level the result that has been partially
attained under the method and the
predecessor project so this market
driven extension went beyond strict
economic messaging and sought to
strengthen the agency of the farmer
based organizations within the value
chain so really make them full-fledged
market actors several these packages
were adapted from national extension
technical documents the regulations
research material technical
recommendations but also inspired by
private sector practices and
requirements so that output could
conform to norm by the end of the
project this footprint and the networks
had developed his own of influence
footprint of 5000 field based agents who
provide services to more than 150,000
farmers and generally the ratio for the
contact points is 1 to 30 and 150 for
one to 50 which is a you know an
efficient way of ensuring constant
outreach the representation of women
within the extension system this private
extension system is still far from
well hi everyone I have we have also
lost to Jean Michel temporarily he's
joining us from Senegal and so there may
be an issue with his phone if you
wouldn't mind hanging tight for just a
moment while we tried to get him back
that would be excellent gotta roll with
the punches on these webinars though the
ones been so great so far so we're
trying to get him back
hello where are we at did you pick up I
really lost maybe 30 seconds of yours
again
I was talking about I was talking about
gender disparity did you hear about that
I kid that's a good place to pick up
okay so the representation of women in
the system is not at parity
20% of database managers are women and
23% of field agents and 18% of Lee
farmers now by comparison 40% of the
total farmer population reached by the
project were women so that comes from
various factors first well corn millet
and irrigated rice are traditionally
male-dominated commodities rain-fed rice
itself is a women's crop with 64% of
women practicing it but the key element
was the differing literacy levels
amongst genders and that played a role
and as did the requirements for mobility
between communities which favors men for
the field agent roles however the
improving rural literacy with young
women is gradually changing that profile
now now the approach here since we were
establishing a footprint for continuity
the idea was to provide continuous
facilitation and gradually have networks
progress in terms of competencies and
autonomy so you the initial objective
was
to have farmers work with their
membership to achieve a productivity
level that were that produced consistent
surpluses gradually progressing to
developing sound input financing plans
and marketing plan finding
intensification solutions in terms of
mechanization practices and gradually
you know being able to manage a web of
various contractual arrangements with
banks insurance companies input
providers it arise even developing
linkages with the National Extension
Service to do information exchange now
this required learning element so we the
project facilitated learning meet you
know from year to year various networks
with me at the regional and the crop
level to exchange best practices and
would discuss issues such as seed
variety performance we discussed quality
standards pricing thresholds climate
response strategies and in the end would
adopt their internal functioning to take
account of the various recommendations
that they made themselves now an
innovative element of the program was to
download completely the data processing
work at the farmer level using very
basic data services off-the-shelf or
open source and having the farmers
manage it themselves so that really had
a big impact in building trust and and
building competency it turned the farmer
led intention into it that's a driven
process people were talking in numbers
it's establishing sowing thresholds in
terms of duration at a certain number of
millimeters you know and assessing
yields with high precision and even
doing crosshair comparisons I mean I've
been told that so
one assisted a crop meeting and said
that he was surprised to have farmers
regular farmers talking about their
three-year yield profile and saying how
they were progressing now the data
getting data processing services at the
farmer level was also a stage program it
was like a learning activity that had
networks
start with a profiling phase like
learning how to profile their membership
so working with static databases but
that were descriptive and enabled them
to really monitor who was who and who
had what in terms of product and
capacity then fall it was followed by a
more analytical learning phase where the
focus was put on how to mine those
statistics and assess their own
performance and finally the more
advanced team's graduated to real-time
data to support more transactional and
tracking activities such as like loan
and insurance application input
procurement and distribution real-time
local weather data collection and just
managing overall crop aggregation now
these these system did not work in
vacuum or let's say in just within the
network I mean throughout the program
these farmers use this data to enter
interact with their partners interact
with government authorities interact you
know with the environment at large and
the the effect has been to build a
climate of trust and really an
evidence-based climate of discussion
both with trading partners farmers and
the government and that was a very
critical element in terms of
reinforcement okay NLM is and I'll be
quick on that one because that's a
subject in itself but I just want to
mention that the level of reinforcement
attained by these farmer organizations
really made them like independent agents
in negotiating with the outside world
and so we call that you know a shift
from a classic vertical structure
you have the central organizing firm or
entity that groups all that and does a
lot of work on the farmers behalf to a
system where the farmers are empowered
to transact with a variety of banks of
clients of service providers inputs of
providers and and are able to get the
best possible price and so that actually
was very conducive in building value and
was an essentially a very data-driven
process just to say that you know these
farmer organizations on their own like
managed successfully more than hundred
fifty million dollars in short-term
loans thirty-four thousand of them
managed to access agricultural insurance
it simulated the emergence of the
mechanized service providers in terms of
land preparation and harvesting etcetera
etcetera that the the indicators are
interesting and but what's more
interesting is the agency that the
networks had in developing those
linkages and those activities they're
now the project closed out last June
okay so that's pretty much a hard stuff
I mean Senegal still eventually will be
getting feed the future support but this
season the farmers have been left
fending for themselves so what happened
did everything go crashing now you see
on the slide in that the ia president of
pepper Maxwell I met with her along with
a few networks across the country went
to visit just to see what was going on I
mean for for the current grain team are
they by they carrying on and what's
interesting is that the majority of them
I mean all the ones I visited I know
that a few smaller organizations don't
yet have the their full autonomy but
most of them have been able to maintain
and grow their service levels of farmers
they maintain low those who were working
with loan applications managing
insurance all these elements
were maintaining their activity and some
even had begun diversifying their
portfolio of activities by monitoring
horticulture and livestock activities
each group we surveyed had developed its
own cost recovery approach through a mix
of rationalization of the extension team
adaptation of the databases to simplify
them introduction or increase in
membership dues and developing service
charges or specific services such as
real-time rainfall tracking and GPS
field surveying some of them had deals
with the insurance company to have
Commission on the management of the
insuring process and you know selling
insurance and also they some of them
negotiated deals with input supplier and
allocated a portion of the volume
rebates to the actual extension work in
some cases brokerage fees were allowed
and margins on sale or you know volumes
allocated to loan reimbursements were
allocated to the funding system and in
some cases agreements with buyers
actually to fund the part of the
Extension Service were negotiated but
there's you know this clear a Latina
that was interesting and that was
permitted by the agency that the
network's had and the knowledge level
they had to develop something that fit
their own circumstances and I well I'm
pretty encouraged by that I'm pretty
happy with that they're doing well now
where are they gonna go so what's the
future challenges
well the network's okay they
demonstrated a capacity to play a very
positive role in the delivery of
extension and more than that value to
farmers I mean that is what keeps them
in business the fact that they're
getting value value in terms of
productivity value in terms of market
access but also value in terms of risk
reduction which is one of the critical
value points for the very small rain-fed
challenge farmers that are challenged
every year by a whole series of risks
there's an expressed need by them
to further develop the model to adapt to
new crops and new services that would
effectively leverage the power of
digital technology so there's a demand
for new technologies adaptive
technologies that accelerate the system
what we're seeing is that the inclusion
of women farmers as fully empowered
agents remains a challenge because of
the size of the farm but there are
solutions that are there but they they
really need to be to be expanded and
diversified but they they do have a
market justification all networks see
the inclusion of their communities use
as an opportunity especially as far as
the you know downstream organization of
the activities such as like data
collection and the various tracking and
management activities where youth really
excel
however networks it should be said that
net these networks cannot replace the
foundational need for public good
knowledge and services that's provided
by agronomic research for the regulation
of the perceived quality and inputs or
the production of meteo data or and
forecast these networks cannot either
self-financed roads or improvements in
rural IT nor can they yet fully finance
large-scale storage infrastructure so
government has to interact with these
groups and and actually they've begun
doing that in Senegal that's what's
interesting I mean they there are clear
platforms that have been developed
between these farmer organizations and
the various decentralized governance
services and that's very promising USAID
is also using these networks to to do as
far as their nutrition program which
gives them a more resilience role just
by their skills and permanence in terms
of organizing local capacity so finally
what I want to say is that the level of
self-organization these neat networks
have it she
can be leveraged by government to
maximize the impact of public investment
and they can become effective relays of
extension messaging but beyond that they
are fully empowered value chain actors
and have to a role to play in that
domain from now on so okay I'm looking
forward to your questions and thank you
for your attention
great thank you so much Joe Michel let's
see we have had a couple of questions
come in for you and then we'll open it
up to some further questions for all
three of our presenters and we have
about 15 minutes left for questions so
Zoe so mark blackett asked is the farmer
owned database system available for
others to use an ongoing our new
projects to help prevent reinventing the
wheel in this case yes well what I want
to say is that there is no software that
for that market farmer owned database
system it's actually a hack a hack of
the various Excel Dropbox and other
software's the more advanced will work
with the open source con care platform
which was engineered into an
agricultural extension activity system
and that also is available on open
source on the web it's more skilled here
that that's required it's not the the
software itself various applications
have been developed and plug into these
systems but they they are independent
and freestanding as we speak so they are
available there will be documentation on
what they represent they that will be
available but the the approaches are a
really open source and based on making
sure that you have people who can manage
the data at the local level and this is
where having farmers that are able to
handle Excel having you know locally
based people that can even do
pivottables and doing pretty
sophisticated analysis really makes it a
very very resilient system one of the
most popular apps now that was a
byproduct of the digital expansion we
did is actually what's up you know and
there's a I think there's a lot of work
to be done in how to hack together
interesting application using either
social media or generic software
great thank you an interesting question
just came in from Sara Huber how are
these farmer organizations in your
example
so high-functioning were they selected
carefully or was there some sort of
significant training provided and also a
separate question how were the bank
loans facilitated and what did they
cover yeah so that that's the question
is always that's where some people often
talk about a senegalese exception in
terms of organizational development I
want to say that an organization like
diplomats for example where you know we
had Nina there talking about her thing
is actually made of you know 12 highly
dysfunctional small farmer groups but
that at one point decided to join forces
and asked us to be empowered and manage
their own thing really you know it's not
like we invented that it was a reaction
to a very dysfunctional top-down
extension system where the lead firm was
actually taking advantage of his father
his position and the farmers told us
rather than dropping the program what if
we got together and provided our own
extension so the key word is motivation
you know and then testing them you want
to have a basic legal structure you want
to have had a certain level of
self-organization but then you want to
give them a motive their initial motive
will be productivity their initial then
it follows on as they see that the risk
is reduced they they'll want to find
markets they'll want to find financing
and this is where you know you have
different middle facilitation components
that come in but you really want to
select the farmer organization that have
a will to succeed and we did capitalize
on the initial group of 10 or 20 farmer
organization but where locally it
generated a series of application and
n-by-n and and then the idea here is to
provide continuity and really build them
up over a period of time but not in
theoretical capacity building but
capacity building that is oriented
towards very clear value proposition by
farmers and that really really creates a
momentum for the bank loans well the
bank loan essentially for the farmer
organizations cover inputs okay there
has been other series of bank loan we
facilitated for their clients what's
interesting with the bank loan is to to
develop the the to make it happen was to
develop how can I say collateral
strategies and risk management strategy
and so this is where inventory
collateral system not necessarily
warehouse receipts but collateral
systems that are oriented towards quick
trading you know warehouse receipt is
about waiting collateral loans are more
about securing the reimbursement by
stocks that are then transferred on to a
buyer and there you have interlocking
credit mechanisms so that that has been
documented on the project there will be
further documentation on how we did that
but this system that secures the product
by quality products really is a very
powerful way of growing of growing loans
of growing finance in a secure way AG
insurance is also very important I mean
the especially for rain-fed zones having
that protects the farmer in the bank as
to the loan reimbursement against the
climate event was also a very very
powerful tool to boost volumes in those
areas and that's actually very popular
with women's organizations to protect
the meager amount that they will put to
adopt input these kinds of index
insurance based on rainfall have gone a
long way with them it's actually very
popular thanks so much Don Michele we
have about ten minutes left for
questions but before we ask a few more I
wanted to open up our ending polls for
all of you to answer we'd appreciate if
you would just take a moment to chime in
on these polls and to let us know how we
can continue to improve our Agri links
webinars going forward
and as a reminder for any of you who do
need to leave early we will be sending
you the recording the transcript and
some additional resources from this
presentation by email and encourage you
to share it with your colleagues if you
think that they would be interested as
well right let's see me show we had a
question from Stafford Francis mom bola
about sustainability what are the
incentives for the network leaders to
continue to maintain their networks
after closeout are they paid or and if
so who pays them well the the farmer
what's interesting with this is that the
leaders are all farmers themselves you
know so they have an interest in
developing this pooling and this
grouping so you know they're not huge
farmers but there'll be farmers who who
have graduated to from let's say two
hectares to let's say 15 hectares
some of them will you know own a tractor
and they they're actually you know very
community-based people and so for them
you know the the organization it's not
just a simple business venture
it does have a social aspect to it okay
and the the leadership it's not just one
person's usually a group of people and
who together you know manage this so
they make their money in there with
their product some of them are let's say
certified seed producers so the group
also provides them with a ready market
and you know they will get involved in
sales and all that also but you know
it's it's really a very grassroots
vision on things and and then they these
organization then negotiate with the
outside world but you know in terms of
needs you know they they have income
expectations that are very reasonable
for people who are present in those
communities and in those environments
and that's what makes it so powerful
it's the same thing for the field agents
people who know I t understand IT but
are used to living in those conditions
who do not want to migrate back to city
thank you Joe Michel and I think on top
of just one final quick question to you
from Judy Payne wondering if you
capitalized on enabling farmers being
able to compare their own data which of
course would open up some questions why
is that other farmer more productive
than me comparing numbers could be an
interesting way of promoting learning
and she was wondering if she did any of
that yes that was the big thing that was
it you know when you when the data is
shared amongst the farmers within the
community not in the project and then a
guy's wife sees on the on a flip chart
that she's actually making more than her
husband in terms of maize production
well that raises interesting discussions
and when you see that the neighboring
Network have higher yields that creates
also interesting discussions so that's
why you know this stage discussion based
on data was so important and really
starting at community level and we found
that farmers actually can understand
histograms you know I mean they they
understand distribution curves and
things like that they really do after a
while and they start talking into very
precise terms and so that's what's so
powerful with it is that the
data processing look is very short and
the the information remains within the
community but gradually also can is
consolidated and transmitted to the
government extension system also and who
actually prizes that data because it's
so it's actually very accurate wonderful
thank you we have still about five
minutes to squeeze in some questions I
wish that we were we could keep going
forever or that we were all at
networking in person because it's been
so great to see the engagement that's
been going on in the chat box
some people challenging each other's
comments asking each other questions
it's really wonderful so thank you to
our audience you are the most important
part of any Agri links webinar and we
really appreciate your engagement before
we officially wrap up I think our last
question or two that came in closer to
the beginning of our presentation that I
think you know still proves relevant so
a question from Ilan Gilbert perhaps
first director you Kristen in some
countries development projects seriously
blur the lines between public and
private extension with HR moving back
and forth which complicates the
institutional strengthening and
sustainability across the board hi yes
thanks for that question I was just
about to write the answer and I was
hoping you were still on but yes we we
have seen this as a big problem in many
countries where you know there's this
so-called poaching or so-called brain
drain often people moving from the
public sector to work for NGOs or
projects or the private sector and so
forth and I guess I would say two major
lessons here one is the need to
strengthen both simultaneously so we
talked a lot about strengthening public
and private sector the producer
organizations the input suppliers the
public people and so forth secondly this
is an issue of incentives and it goes
back to the overall professionalization
of extension and advisory services and I
think that's something many public
services in particular need to pay
attention to and we have some examples
from Uganda and South Africa on that
related to regulation certification and
all these things but incentives are so
poor for rural extension agents who work
for for government or you know district
or federal systems or whatever this this
needs to be looked at and improved
great Thank You Kristen um
and let's see ha ha
so we've had so many great questions and
we've been I think answering as many of
them as we could and we will certainly
be sharing the chatbox transcripts with
the presenters after the fact in case
there's any opportunity to include a few
more questions in our post-event
resources and I also have a few more
that I will copy and paste some written
answers as soon as we wrap up perhaps
maybe the last question I know that Joe
Michele that you touched on gender
integrate integration but it's always a
question that comes up with Julie
every other links webinar people are
wanting more information about how to
integrate gender concerns into
programming and Lea on the kinga at the
beginning asked how do extension
advisory services ensure gender
integration into their program and there
was someone who wanted to just elaborate
more on what you said so perhaps you
could touch on a couple of important
gender issues before we wrap up yes okay
one thing I want to say that was
interesting is we check the age of the
death dates and the field agents who
work with data and what's interesting is
that men were 30 years old on average
and women were actually younger they
were 28 and also what we saw is that
even though in Cosimo's witness literacy
was very low when you look at the
younger generation there's like a
literacy surge for the you know the 10
to 18 year old who eventually become
candidates for being future field agents
and and hold these kind of of management
capacity so what I want to say is that
even if in I mean in the poor countries
that
the case and so I really encourage
projects to be poised for that for that
little that way of literate and trained
women like I said you know 10th grade is
accessible I mean for pretty
sophisticated data processing you can
for field agent level it can be less
than that and you really want to
integrate them in there one of the
elements are saying is that for Williams
organization women have generally
smaller plot sizes and are concentrated
in various pools of areas and and that
requires having a strategy that adapted
to that so so that because they have
less mobility so you can have more you
know responsible field agents per basin
and rather than having a multi Basin
approach so that's also another another
element but I also want to say that the
the strongest network leaders are
generally women it's in the top
management posts that's been our
experience and that's why you really
want to promote that that integration
and all that I think another domain that
can be very strong in bringing women
into those extension system is that
those networks want to co-op young
people and and very often like women's
group will co-op young women I mean you
want to make sure that that happens
what's important is is really to promote
that integration throughout the program
and that's where projects have a role to
play but once they've been in the system
for a few for a few cycles the women
then develop entrepreneurial programs
and a bit like what Robert was
describing you know some of them migrate
and and can become village agents
connected with banks with insurance
companies with input distributors a bit
like that I mean the networks are are
kind of
but they're also a ready market for
those entrepreneurial businesses for
youth and women are very good in that I
just want to say that the young woman
you saw in the slide I presented is now
as graduated from being a database
manager for a write company and is now
created her own company as a write
aggregator she she actually owns a car
now wonderful thank you John Michelle
all right we are 2 minutes past the hour
so we're going to go ahead and
officially wrap up this webinar I would
like to extend a sincere thank you to
our presenters to our participants and
to the Agri links team who always
supports these webinars with enthusiasm
and excellent support so thank you all
for attending and keep your eye on the
other links newsletter for announcements
for upcoming webinars thank you all and
have a great rest of your day